0:00:13.369,0:00:15.650
I come from a village called Pilikwi.
It's near Serowe.
yes several and
I was ill.
I have a headache.
And after that headache
in 2 or 3 days
the herpes come out from this side.
When I went to the private doctor
he told me it was the sign of HIV.
I was confused because that time,
it was the time when this HIV
0:00:57.960,0:00:59.540
was not
normal like these days.
So my doctor talked to me.
After he tested and saw that the test came out positive he
sat with me and talked to me first,
after that he told me I am HIV positive.
0:01:17.340,0:01:19.990
When I was still talking to them,
someone told me about AIDS Research Trials
at Harvard.
The staff at Tsepho,
they are very friendly, very polite.
They talk to people very nicely.
So I met Dr. Westler
for the first time.
So he talked to me
and then he helped me very nicely.
And he's the one who gave me the medication for the first time.
These days, because more people have been affected.
0:02:07.430,0:02:09.069
Now, these days,
the medication is there,
People are taking the medication.
So each and everyone has hope that maybe I will live,yeah,
longer.